[Music]
let's turn to a highly-anticipated
celebration of another kind today was
supposed to be the day the Dance Moms
star Abby Lee Miller would be released
from prison
unfortunately for Abby that dream just
went bust a source tells ET Miller is
definitely not getting out today a major
blow after she was told today would be
her last day behind bars Abby Lee has
served seven months of her 366 day
sentence so far she pled guilty to
bankruptcy fraud in 2016 this is what
Miller looks like now at least a hundred
pounds lighter than when she went in
thanks to gastric sleeve surgery she had
right before her sentencing our cameras
were there with her last year as she
underwent the procedure I hate what I
look like on TV and you know I want to I
want to look better nothing makes the
mothers more jealous our source tells us
the Dance Moms star is looking forward
to her new life outside of prison
adding the sky's the limit and while
some things have been absolutely
horrific in prison some things are
pretty much the same
another source adds Miller will be going
under the knife again very soon she'll
be furthering her physical
transformation with a tummy tuck and
skin removal surgery this is been a long
time coming for quite a few years I now
feel like I'm in control of my own life
but Abby Lee won't be completely free
she'll be living in a halfway house upon
a release and according to our source
we'll have lots and lots to say about
her time away now under federal
guidelines with good behavior Abby Lee
could be free as early as May after
serving just 85% of her sentence but she
still will have two years of supervised
release where she will be monitored by
the United States Department of
probation my wife's a lawyer that's how
I have all that legal ease but I gotta
say who goes to jail and comes out
looking better and that looks great
right
[Music]